i have been on the road for the last
five months
i don't know man i just really thinking
the worst of people
really am you see some of the animals
some of the animals i see like i was in
the airport the other day right
i'm sitting there waiting for my flight
just hating my life and this watching
this
watching this lady she's eating egg
mcmuffins like plural it just threw like
three of them
right down her throat like a pelican
just like right down her gullet
and when she was done she wiped her face
with the bag
ah with the bag she's not even like a
gentleman like no i'll just do the
corners
she just got a straight razor shave
that's an absolute
animal i saw this other dude he was so
out of shape he was like trying to itch
his back and he couldn't reach it
so he walked up to a support pole
that was holding up an entire floor of
the airport
and just walks up and he just starts
like rubbing up against it
like a grizzly bear
just a [ __ ] animal
dude i am so pro swine flu it's it's
like ridiculous
i want it we need a plague i'm telling
you we need
a plague it's got to happen and don't be
afraid it's only good it's only going to
kill the weak
you know seriously put on a sweater
take some vitamins you got to be fine
you got to let mother nature do her
thing man she keeps trying to help us
out
and we won't let her do it
keeps trying to thin the herd every
single time like oh get down to get your
vaccination
why why so egg mcmuffin lady can breathe
with the back fat guy you know
it's got to happen you got to let her do
it seriously plague it's like nature's
forest fire you know
just let it burn out all the dead wood
wow i swear to god we're the only we're
the only species that saves the week
we really are lions don't do that [ __ ]
you know lion gets a little thorn in his
paw and everybody thought
you have an intervention how you feeling
is everything all right you need some
penicillin
and it's like [ __ ] them
that's why there's no traffic on the
serengeti
got a bunch of lions just standing there
and gridlocked like what the [ __ ] is
going on up there
dude go you [ __ ] go
hour later you get up there there's some
hyena licking his balls like oh that was
a big holder right
but like you never saw that before oh by
all means slow down and look at it
[Laughter]
it's just one more way of reducing your
liberty and reminding you that they can
[ __ ] with you anytime they want as long
as you put up with it
as long as you put up with it which
means of course
any time they want because that's what
americans do now they're always willing
to trade
away a little of their freedom in
exchange for the feeling
the illusion of security what we have
now
is a completely neurotic population
obsessed
with security and safety and crime and
drugs and cleanliness
and hygiene and germs there's another
thing
germs where did the sudden fear of germs
come from
in this country have you noticed this
the media constantly running stories
about all the latest infections
salmonella e coli hantavirus bird flu
and and americans are they panic easily
so now everybody's running around
scrubbing this and spraying that and
overcooking their food and repeatedly
washing their hands
trying to avoid all contact with germs
it's ridiculous
and it goes to ridiculous lengths in
prisons
before they give you a lethal injection
they swab your arm with alcohol
it's true it's true
it's true well
well they don't want you to get an
infection and you can see their point
wouldn't want some guy to go to hell and
be sick
it would take a lot of the sportsmanship
out of the whole execution
fear it germs why these [ __ ] [ __ ]
you can't even get a decent hamburger
anymore they cook the [ __ ] out of
everything now because everybody's
afraid of food
poisoning hey where's your sense of
adventure take a [ __ ] chance will you
you know how many people die in this
country from food poisoning every year
nine thousand that's all it's a minor
risk
take a [ __ ] chance bunch of goddamn
[ __ ]
besides what do you think you have an
immune system for
it's for killing germs but it needs
practice
it needs germs to practice on
so so listen
so listen if you kill all the germs
around you and live a completely sterile
life
then when germs do come along you're not
going to be prepared and never mind
ordinary germs
what are you going to do when some super
virus comes along that turns your vital
organs into liquid [ __ ]
i'll tell you what you're going to do
you're going to get sick you're going to
die and you're going to deserve it
because you're [ __ ] weak and you got
to [ __ ] weak immune system
hey all right
let me tell you a true story about
immunization okay
when i was a little boy in new york city
in the 1940s
we swam in the hudson river and it was
filled with raw
sewage okay we swam in raw sewage
you know to cool off
[Music]
and at that time the big fear was polio
thousands of kids died from polio every
year but you know something in my
neighborhood
no one ever got polio no one ever you
know why
because we swam in raw sewage
it strengthened our immune systems the
polio never had a prayer we were
tempered in raw
[ __ ] so
so personally i never take any special
precautions against
germs i don't shy away from people who
sneeze and cough i don't wipe off the
telephone i don't cover the toilet seat
and if i drop food on the floor i pick
it up and eat it
i eat it yes i do
[Music]
uh so we're gonna start with i really
miss sarge uh i
i'm really hate to see it go man i
really was happy watching chinese people
walking around
uh not trying to cough you know you know
but i just love watching chinese people
get the pressure applied looking at them
like waiting for them to cough you know
you when you was working with him he was
just looking around
if you cough
if this chinese dude coughs it was just
fantastic because every other
disease they blame on black people i
can't get enough of it
i'm watching uh tv monkey parks and
it was doing some magical disease white
people breaking out with this was
all and uh and so i'm looking and
they're doing the report and they show a
composite sketch of some
rat uh from africa which
which which means he's black and they
drew it
first of all i'm like what's this how do
you know the difference between some
some uh
black rat and some rat from the bronx
that's
the puerto rican hat so they they might
as well drew
a hat backwards and so
so this is the monkey box culprit watch
out for them watch out for the dirty
black rat and then uh uh
it attacked it attacked uh now white
people don't really have an
animal representative of themselves
but if he was to think of a few one
would be a bald eagle and the other
would be a prairie dog and that's what
it attacked so it's almost just like a
newscaster be on the lookout for
something
right uh he he
uh bid uh some poor defenseless uh
prairie dog just watching the game and
stole his wallet and bent him in the
shoulder and gave him
i'm watching uh this bug show with the
locusts man
you know black locust from africa black
rough whoa watch out for black
locusts africanized that's what they
call
africanized big black locusts watch out
because they
they eat up all the crops and they don't
tip and
watch out watch out for the locusts
[Applause]
and y'all know about the monkey monkey
got charged up with all kind of the
monkey a's
ebola i'm not even really scared of aids
anymore
i mean cause how can you with magic you
see magic johnson he looks fantastic
i can't be afraid he looks wonderful
he's had aids for 15 years
what kind of age he got the good kind i
want
he's been he's been opening movie
theaters
and starbucks for the last 15 years i
want that kind of age give me that
make me a better entrepreneur i need
that
[Music]
patricia got aids good i want to open a
trucking company because
this crowd is tough man okay like you
know chinese people didn't
laugh after that but the black people in
the chinese people wrote they all
laughing at the thing right but they
that's young girls for you boys young
girls do that y'all the only thing good
about young girls y'all young girls you
know you're young
look delicious you know other than that
and they're getting bigger too man these
young brothers man
damn you see them what i think of stuff
they put in the chicken and all that
stuff all that
that that you know what i mean they
walking around big i saw this woman
walking down the street i was like
damn you fine how old are you she was
like four
[Applause]
i said you got some nice titties